now good afternoon thank you for joining
us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Christian Casitas an emotional plea this
afternoon for a man to turn himself in
police say he killed his neighbor over a
parking spot the argument turned into a
deadly shooting last Tuesday on Tipper
Avenue near Nellis and Hacienda Victoria
Saha joins us in studio after speaking
with the victim's girlfriend Victoria
34 year old Christopher Allen's
girlfriend says he loved cars so much so
that it was this silver Dodge Challenger
he was working on right before he was
killed Not only was his life taken over
a parking spot but now the family says
they can't even begin to heal until the
person who did this is caught
anyway I was just calling to say I love
you that spontaneous call on the morning
of October 18th would be the last time
Stacey Owens would hear her boyfriend's
voice again you wake up you see someone
you talk to them and then that's that
you don't see them ever again hours
later police see an argument over
parking led a neighbor to shoot and kill
34-year-old Christopher Allen in his
doorway they have to kick this door down
to get him Owen says she believes
Allen's car may have been in the way of
the neighbor's driveway while he and
another neighbor were working on it
suspect produced a handgun and fired a
couple rounds at which time our victim
was struck the shooting caused panic in
the neighborhood causing the school that
their daughter attempts to go on
lockdown Owen was not aware of what
happened to Allen and was trying to text
and call him when she got to the
neighborhood it was surrounded by police
and crime scene tape you can clearly see
from down the street that Chris is part
you know weird and then that's when now
like kind of went into Panic police say
the person responsible took off we can't
keep living like this with him being out
there I went to the neighbor's house to
speak with the family but there was no
answer your best friend actually every
single day and like you guys have all
these plans
I mean it just is gone as Owens
continues to remember the love of her
life his Dodge silver Challenger remains
parked outside as a dedicated neighbor
continues to work on it finishing what
Alan started
his girlfriend tells me they had plans
to get married next year and I asked
Metro Police why they haven't sent out
the name or a description of the alleged
shooter if he still hasn't been caught
all they could tell me is that their
investigation is still open and ongoing
Kirsten Victoria thank you Christopher
Allen was from Milwaukee his girlfriend
tells Victoria they plan on having a
funeral there in a couple of weeks